muy bien la respiración celular incluye
las vías metabólicas de la glucólisis el
ciclo de krebs y la cadena de transporte
de electrones como se representa en las
figuras aquí tenemos las figuras de la
glucólisis el ciclo de krebs y la cadena
de transporte de electrones si todo esto
te parece completamente desconocido te
invito a ver los vídeos en khan academy
que hablan de la glucólisis el ciclo de
krebs y la cadena de transporte de
electrones y de la respiración celular
en general
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer este
problema es un muy buen repaso de todos
esos temas en la respiración celular los
carbohidratos y otros metabolitos se
oxidan es decir son despojados de sus
electrones y las reacciones de
transferencia de energía resultantes
apoyan la síntesis de atp utilizando la
información anterior describe una
contribución de cada uno de los
siguientes puntos en la síntesis de atp
muy bien el primero es el catabolismo de
la glucosa en la glucólisis y la
oxidación de piruvato el segundo es la
oxidación de moléculas intermediarias en
el ciclo de krebs y el tercero es la
formación de un gradiente de protones
por la cadena de transporte de
electrones ahora cada uno de estos
enunciados pueden parecer un poco
intimidantes
pero lo que nos están pidiendo es
describir como la glucólisis y la
oxidación de piruvato contribuyen a la
síntesis de atp describe como el ciclo
de krebs y recuerda que el ciclo de
krebs es esencialmente
a 100 de estas moléculas intermediarias
para producir cosas que son útiles para
la síntesis de atp y luego la formación
del gradiente de protones por la cadena
de transporte de electrones bueno eso es
lo que la cadena de transporte de
electrones hace toma electrones de alta
energía del nh o del fadh 2 y luego
conforme esos electrones de alta energía
van a estados de energía cada vez más
bajos bombean protones de hidrógeno a
través de la membrana y cuando vuelven a
entrar se utilizan para sintetizar atp
así que vamos a responder esta pregunta
tenemos que escribir una contribución de
cada uno de estos enunciados así que
vamos a comenzar con la glucólisis si
miramos aquí arriba hay más de una
contribución podemos ver que se puede
fosforilada estos dos a bp para producir
2 atp así que esa es una contribución
que podríamos describir podríamos decir
que se están produciendo esto
y es que pueden proporcionar su protón
de hidrógeno y más importante que eso
proporcionan los electrones de alta
energía para la cadena de transporte de
electrones más adelante se puede ver por
aquí o podríamos decir que se está
produciendo la acetil coa que puede
entrar en el ciclo de krebs y que se
utiliza para producir gtp o más
nh o fadh 2 así que todas estas son
contribuciones y puesto que sólo tenemos
que escribir una de ellas voy a
describir la más directa y evidente
aunque puedes utilizar cualquiera de
estas voy a escribir
fosforilación
dos moléculas de adp
para producir los atp
y podría describir varias contribuciones
más pero esa es una buena y sólo tenemos
que describir una contribución muy bien
la oxidación de las moléculas
intermediarias en el ciclo de krebs
hablar de la oxidación de las moléculas
intermediarias es sólo hablar de que
cada una de estas moléculas siguen
siendo oxidadas y a medida que son
oxidadas podemos utilizar eso para
reducir otras cosas incluyendo n además
a nh así cuando se reduce está ganando
electrones y observa que el n además es
positivo por lo que se convierte en nh
que es una molécula neutra y estos nh se
utilizan más adelante en la cadena de
transporte de electrones para bombear
protones de hidrógeno a través de la
membrana que luego se utilizan en la
fosforilación oxidativa para producir el
atp a medida que se regresan a través de
la membrana por lo tanto se puede hablar
de los n h
efe
o podrías hablar de la creación directa
de gtp que puede ser utilizada para
crear atp así que cualquiera de estos
está muy bien así que voy a describir
uno de ellos voy a escribir
la reducción
de n además
a nh que se utiliza
en la cadena
de transporte de electrones
para crear
un gradiente
de protones
y una vez más podría hablar sobre los
gps o podría hablar de él
efe a de h2 que se está creando la
formación de un gradiente de protones
por la cadena de transporte de
electrones bueno como los protones
fluyen a favor del gradiente de regreso
al otro lado de la membrana estimulan a
la atp cintas a que crean atp a partir
de adp así que conforme los protones
fluye
a favor
del gradiente a través
de la membrana
activa a la atp sin tasa
la cual fosforila
a dp para producir
atp y una vez más si todo lo que estoy
diciendo aquí te parece desconocido y si
estos diagramas son ajenos a ti si no te
traen un recuerdo placentero a la mente
te invito a ver los vídeos en khan
academy donde podrás conocer un poco más
acerca de estas cosas de las que estoy
hablando muy bien ahora vamos a ver si
podemos contestar el inciso b utiliza
cada una de las siguientes observaciones
para justificar la afirmación de que la
glucólisis ocurrió por primera vez en un
ancestro común de todos los organismos
vivos que así todos los organismos
existentes realizan glucólisis así que
para que este sea el caso
lo más probable
es que
la glucólisis
fuera desarrollada
por un ancestro común
y seleccionada
de manera natural
en vez
de haber sido
desarrollada
de forma independiente
en múltiples ramas
del árbol
filogenético
el hecho de que casi todos los
organismos existentes realizan
glucólisis en teoría podría haber
ocurrido de manera independiente y que
haya sido seleccionado fuertemente pero
si algo sucede en casi todos los
organismos es muy probable que haya sido
desarrollado en una etapa muy muy
temprana en un organismo primitivo que
es un antepasado común y que fue
seleccionado y continúa siendo
seleccionado y es por eso que seguimos
viéndolo
muy bien la glucólisis se produce en
condiciones anaeróbicas
la tierra primitiva
tenía poco oxígeno
en la atmósfera
por lo tanto
la vida temprana
tenía que metabolizar
los azúcares
en un medio anaeróbico
es decir en un ambiente que no tiene
oxígeno por lo que una vez más esto
justifica la afirmación de que la
glucólisis se produjo por primera vez en
un ancestro común de todos los
organismos la glucólisis solo ocurre en
el sitio sol
la vida primitiva
no tenía
por hoy anhelos
y contenidos
por una membrana celular
por lo que
el hecho
de que solo ocurre
en el cito sol
es consistente
con que haya ocurrido
por primera vez
en un antepasado
primitivo
común en el siguiente vídeo veremos los
incisos c y d